[Música]
ucrania de entrar en su día 102 de la
guerra en here son una ciudad que los
rusos se tomaron al comienzo de la
ofensiva y donde el ejército ucraniano
ha recuperado algo de terreno no se
puede hacer un contraataque
significativo por carencia de armamento
moderno
grecia lucha contra un incendio que ha
destruido casas y automóviles cerca de
la capital atenas las autoridades
trabajan para extinguir las llamas
alimentadas por los fuertes vientos el
país se encuentra en alerta a raíz de
los incendios del año pasado que
devastaron el territorio
cientos de personas salieron a las
calles de perú para exigir la renuncia
del presidente pedro castillo las
manifestaciones terminaron que en
choques con la policía que el hito que
avanzarán hacia un lugar donde se
encontraban seguidores del mandatario
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos en ucrania y
vamos a gerson una ciudad que los rusos
se tomaron al comienzo de la guerra pero
que aunque el ejército ucraniano ha
recuperado algo de terreno no puede
hacer un contraataque significativo por
ahora pues carece de armamento moderno
reporteros de france24 en inglés fueron
hasta uno de los frentes militares en
esta región
hasta hace unas semanas la posición de
este regimiento ucraniano estaba en
primera línea los rusos están ahora a
seis kilómetros de distancia al
concentrar sus esfuerzos en la región
del donbass a veces han permitido a kiev
recuperar terreno en otros lugares como
aquí en el norte de gerson hay poca otro
poco
noté que la mayor parte del tiempo solo
defendemos nuestras posiciones pero en
algunos lugares contra atacamos esta
mañana nuestra fuerza aérea bombardeó
posiciones enemigas
el ejército ucraniano ha retomado
algunas posiciones clave en la zona pero
un contraataque mayor aún no está en la
agenda por ahora la meta es impedir una
nueva entrega de arma rusas pero esta
unidad del ejército regular tiene poco
armamento construido para ese objetivo
como lo muestra esta pieza de artillería
de la época soviética
necesitamos cañones ms 777 que pueden
disparar hasta 30 kilómetros de
distancia y esta arma antitanque sólo lo
podemos usar una vez
pero el javelin puede recargarse
continuamente con nuevos misiles meteor
crater las entregas de armas
occidentales aún no han tenido efecto
importante en el frente el ejército
ucraniano carece de artillería moderna y
lanzadores de misiles ante ataque de
última generación como éste ya velina
americano este joven soldado dice que ha
podido hacer buen uso de la eficacia del
arma en el período de gates foundation
no sólo instructor quien fue entrenado
en la región de kiev por un instructor
americano información duró dos semanas
en la región de lugansk destruimos unos
20 objetivos con esto todo esto
decepciona
y nos faltan armas como esta para cubrir
todas nuestras posiciones en el frente
de los oficiales ucranianos han dicho en
repetidas ocasiones que el suministro de
armas modernas podría cambiar el curso
de la guerra
y un incendio afectó varios suburbios
del sur de grecia las autoridades
helenas movilizaron un importante
dispositivo para sofocar el incendio y
evacuaron a las zonas afectadas hasta el
momento solo se reportan daños
materiales
rafael pérez nos trae más detalles
incendio en zona residencial de atenas
moviliza cientos de bomberos
siniestro inició en glyfada un suburbio
en el sur de atenas en entrevista a la
prensa local el alcalde de la zona hizo
saber la gravedad del suceso la
atmósfera es sofocante tenemos
dificultad para respirar el fuego dañó
al menos 20 casas vehículos estacionados
y amplias áreas de vegetación según
funcionarios
un bombero fue trasladado al hospital
por problemas respiratorios sin embargo
hasta el momento no se han reportado
heridos aunque no se ha hecho un
pronunciamiento oficial sobre el inicio
de las llamas medios regionales ubican
el epicentro en una central eléctrica de
alto voltaje la agencia griega de
protección civil realizó un llamado de
emergencia a los barrios vecinos para
que los residentes evacuaran
recibimos un mensaje del ministerio de
evacuar nuestros hogares así lo hicimos
y estamos mirando desde la distancia
estábamos un poco asustados pero ahora
creo que la situación es mejor
más de 130 bomberos intentan sofocar la
situación con la ayuda de 6 aviones
cisterna y cuatro helicópteros
misma semana la comisión europea
confirmó que unos 200 miembros de
cuerpos de rescate y equipos técnicos
proporcionados por la unión continental
se desplegarán en la nación helena
previendo grandes conflagraciones como
las vividas en el verano pasado y vamos
ahora a francia donde intentan
implementar el ejercicio diario antes de
las clases en las escuelas primarias
como respuesta al sedentarismo la
iniciativa busca que los alumnos se
sientan con más energía para estudiar
tras la actividad física andrés
granadillo nos cuenta más
hacemos deporte así que después tenemos
más energía para trabajar y para el
resto del día
correr por 30 minutos estirar y luego
estudiar esto es lo que hacen más de 500
alumnos en la región de bretaña en el
oeste de francia con el programa
'muévete bus en francés para luchar
contra el sedentarismo
me gusta esta actividad porque en lugar
de quedarnos en la el aula salimos
hacemos calentamientos ejercicios y
jugamos un poco
me gusta
en la clase de cedric sorte la actividad
deportiva se da al inicio de la tarde
cuando los niños vuelven del almuerzo
allí hacen un calentamiento más
elaborado y dirigido por otros jóvenes
el hecho de que sea diario hace que se
convierta en un ritual por lo que para
los niños es importante ritualizar las
cosas como el dictado el cálculo mental
el deporte se convierten también en un
ritual en este primer año se escogieron
18 clases para seguir esta actividad en
una plataforma comparten imágenes de las
sesiones y cada semana reciben en vídeo
mensajes de ánimo de algún jugador la
idea inspirada en un proyecto escocés es
ahora implementado en francia por el
gobierno de manuel macro para que la
actividad física se vuelva tan
importante como las matemáticas o la
historia
pasamos a américa latina' en
enfrentamientos con la policía termino
una manifestación en perú contra el
presidente pedro castillo con carteles
banderas y bocinas cientos de personas
pertenecientes a movimientos sociales y
partidos políticos salieron a las calles
de lima este sábado gritando consignas
contra el mandatario y acusándolo de
corrupción los uniformados interceptaron
la marcha cuando se dirigía a la plaza
san martín en el centro histórico y
donde se encontraban seguidores del
castillo lo que provocó choques sin que
se presentaran hechos graves
decirle el señor pedro ocasión renuncié
que tenga dignidad y que deje en paz y
es porque lo está llevando a la
ding ding
tiene que irse tiene que por dignidad
dejar el poder se vaya castillo estamos
viendo el país está destruyendo la
economía
este estado está libertaria
espero que él y todos corruptos el
gobierno ecuatoriano de guillermo lasso
lanzó un nuevo proceso para regular la
migración de venezolanos el decreto 436
permite que quienes hayan entrado al
país antes del 3 de junio de 2022 puedan
optar por la visa de residencia temporal
y además le dio una amnistía a los
migrantes y a sus familias que tengan el
permiso de permanencia vencido sin
embargo existe un vacío pues la norma
sólo aplica para los migrantes regulares
y por lo menos el 62% de los venezolanos
entraron a ecuador de manera irregular
según acnur
en noticias de colombia a la corte
constitucional volvió a fallar a favor
de juan pablo barrientos un reconocido
periodista que ha venido investigando y
denunciando la pederastia en la iglesia
católica y ahora la arquidiócesis de la
ciudad de medellín deberá proporcionar
la información de sacerdotes
presuntamente involucrados en denuncias
de abusos sexuales una medida que podría
ayudar a arrojar luz sobre el actuar de
la iglesia previamente hablamos con juan
pablo barrientos en la ciudad de bogotá
quien nos comentó que consecuencias
legales podría haber si no se le entrega
información completa y correcta
pues no entregarla implicaría que
monseñor estaría incurriendo en un
delito que es el delito de falsedad
ideológica en documento privado
en otros países del mundo la iglesia
católica ha reconocido que esa
información ha destruido la ha quemado
es el caso de alemán y en alemania los
obispos salieron y dijeron ya esa
información no existe y es muy probable
que eso no exista aquí en colombia en
medellín en bogotá en cali en sonsón
rionegro otras diócesis del país con las
cuales tengo una disputa legal para que
entreguen estos archivos el hecho es que
aquí ya hay una orden de jueces
constitucionales y si bien los obispos
de colombia creen que el derecho
canónico está por encima del derecho
ordinario vamos a ver qué reacción toma
ahora el arzobispo cuando es el máximo
tribunal el que por segunda vez en dos
años le está ordenando entregar esta
información repito si no la entrega
estaría incurriendo en un delito y los
jueces de la república hasta podrían
ordenar su arresto o sancionarlo porque
aquí estamos hablando de un estado de
derecho como es colombia en el cual las
decisiones de los jueces se tienen que
acatar
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]